now that we have a parameterization for
the boundary of our surface right up
here let's think a little bit about what
the line integral and this was the left
side of our original stokes theorem
statement what the line integral over
the path c
of f
of f our original vector field f dot d r
is going to be and now this once again
this r we're talking about the path of
this of this boundary right over here c
not c one that we did to kind of get
some of our foundational material going
so f dot
f dot d r
f
dot
d r well we remember we remember what f
is f is all the way up here it's i j and
k components were just p q and r so
that's kind of easy to remember but
let's think about what dr is equal to
let's think about what dr is and we're
gonna have to break out a little bit of
our three-dimensional our multi-variable
chain rule right over here so dr
d
r
is the same thing as d r
d t
times dt so we really just have to
figure out what the derivative of r with
respect to t and this is we have to
break out a little bit of the chain rule
so let me write this down so dr
dr
dt is going to be equal to the
derivative of x with respect to t times
i
plus the derivative of y with respect to
t i'm just taking the derivative with
respect to t j
and now we're gonna have to break the
because z is a function of x which is a
which is which is a function of t and z
is also a function of y which is a
function of t we're gonna have to break
out our three our multivariable chain
rule
so if we want to take the derivative of
z with respect to t i'll do it
separately here and then i'll write it
down down here the derivative of z with
respect to t you really the way i
conceptualize is all what's all the
different ways that z can change from a
change in t
well it could change because x is
changing due to a change in t so we
could have so z could change due to x
the partial of z with respect to x when
x changes with respect to t
but then that's not the only way that z
can change we have to add to that how z
can change with respect to y partial of
z with respect to y times how how how
fast or how y is changing with respect
to t and this is just our multi-variable
chain rule and so this is dz
dz dt so i'll just write it right over
here and i'll use slightly different
notation that's consistent with what we
were doing before and it'll help make
things a little bit clearer so we'll
agree it's going to be the partial of z
with respect to x
dx
dt
plus
the actually let me write it this way
plus the partial of z with respect to y
d y d t
and then we're going to multiply
everything times our k
we are going to multiply everything
times our k
so with this out of the way so if we
wanted if we wanted what dr is dr is
just going to be this whole thing times
this whole thing times dt so let's do
that so now we can rewrite our line
integral right over here and we're going
to now go into the t domain and so t is
going to go between a and b t is going
to be between a and b and f dot dr
remember f components were just the
functions p q and r
and each of those were functions of x y
and z and z is a function of x and y so
we'll have to think about all of that in
a little bit use more a little more of
our multivariable chain rule but when we
take the dot products we're just going
to take the corresponding components and
multiply them so it is going to be i
actually let me just copy and paste so f
is let me rewrite it down here our
vector field f
our vector field f and i'm going to
write a little bit shorter our vector
field f is p
times i plus q
times j plus r
times k so when we take our dot product
of f dot dr
we're essentially taking the dot product
of this and this and we have to throw a
dt at the end so we're going to get
we're going to get
p
times dx dt
p times dx
dt
plus q
times d y dt
d y
d dt plus r
plus r times all of this business over
here
times all of this business which is the
partial of z with respect to x
dx
dt
plus the partial of z with respect to y
d y
d t
and then we have to multiply all of this
times d t we can't forget that part
right over there so we're going to
multiply all of this
all of this right here times dt now i'm
going to leave you there in this video
just because i'm afraid of making
careless mistakes
what we're going to do now is we're
going to rearrange this whole thing
recognize that this is the same thing as
this right over here then that gives it
a form that we can apply green's theorem
using this boundary right over here and
then when we do a little bit more
algebraic manipulation we're going to
see that this thing simplifies to this
thing right over here and proves stokes
theorem for our special case